bonsoir interview bonsoir alors on voit
un séisme deux pays une solidarité
vraiment différente envers les deux pays
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire dans
l'immédiat pour aider la Syrie
mais je pense qu'il faut il faut avoir
tout un rôle d'empathie il faut pousser
notre gouvernement aussi qui est prêt à
donner de l'aide aux victimes du séisme
en Turquie qui est aussi qui envoie
aussi de l'aide en Syrie il faut faire à
travers des organisations qui sont
fiables on a quelques-unes déjà sur
place
mais c'est pas ça français une dame il y
a la Croissant rouge il y a les casques
blancs donc il y en a donc ça ça aide
quand même qui est déjà des
organisations humanitaires qui soient
actives sur le terrain non tout à fait
parce que vous savez on n'arrête pas de
dire c'est une course contre la montre
et donc ça veut vraiment aider les gens
oui il y a ça se détiennent en trois
étapes il y a les recherches et
sauvetages des gens qui sont soudés les
qui sont ensevelies et après ça traiter
les blessés et aussi
s'assurer que les gens on répond à leurs
besoins vitaux qui soient de les couvrir
de leur donner un abri de leur donner à
manger à boire et donc quand on est déjà
sur place mais on peut on peut être
actif notamment
qui est là dans la première heure on
traitait 200 personnes tout de suite
donc quand on est là on peut déjà donner
un coup de main on peut déjà mobiliser
tout de suite rediriger l'aide donc
c'est quand même une petite longueur
d'avance mais évidemment les gens se
plaignent qu'ils ont pas droit à la même
mobilisation qui a un convoi en Turquie
l'aide internationale le fait que soit
le pays qui soit en guerre civile depuis
12 ans ça vient quand même compliqué
considérablement la possibilité
d'assistance étrangères non absolument
et c'est depuis le début de ce conflit
là c'est un casse-tête on passe une
résolution à tous les six mois pour
permettre que l'aide humanitaire
traverse de la Turquie en grande partie
vers la série du Nord et c'est compliqué
on vient juste de reconduire cette
résolution là 26 72 le 9 janvier mais
même à ça on sait que ça va passer
probablement au compte-goutte alors
comment comment faire pour acheminer
cette aide est-ce que ça prendrait un
pont aérien par exemple
ça va être difficile parce qu'il faut
trouver l'endroit pour ne pas aérien
puis après ça faut avoir un accord de
trêve il faut que ça soit accepté par
toutes les parties donc c'est quand même
quelque chose qui ne se fera pas
instantané alors quels sont les besoins
les plus urgents là pour les pour les
gens qu'on voit parce que évidemment il
y a le tremblement de terre mais aussi
un froid glacial qu'est-ce qui est le
plus urgent mais c'est sûr que il y a
les activités de sauvetage et recherche
ça il faut que ça se fasse et on a un
une fenêtre pour faire ça qui est 3-5
jours dépendamment donc plus il fait
froid plus ça va être difficile la
survie des gens aussi dépend de comment
comment ils sont
ensevelis le espace pour l’oxygène ils
ont accès à de l'eau donc tout ça peut
jouer mais on sait que ça joue entre 300
jours les défis sont immenses avec un
tremblement de terre vous étiez en Haïti
c'est que tout est détruit autour on
pense au sauvetage et aux recherches
mais il y a pas juste ça aussi il y a
beaucoup plus que ça
énorme parce qu'en fait c'est le système
est détruit donc on a des gens qui sont
blessés mais on a des gens qui ont des
maladies chroniques qui tout d'un coup
leur médicament sont ensevelis leurs
médicaments pour leur hypertension leur
médicament pour leur diabète on fait
comment les pharmacies aussi sont
ensevelies donc ça c'est un enjeu donc
faut pas oublier que dans la réponse
dans un tremblement de terre c'est que
la vie continue les gens ont leur
maladie il faut les traiter les mamans
vont encore faire des accouchements moi
je me rappelle en Haïti on avait des
orthopédistes qui étaient là pour pour
s'occuper des gens qui avaient des bras
cassés puis au final il faisait des
césariennes aussi parce que la
population évidemment à toutes sortes de
besoins et donc si les gens veulent
aider parce qu'il y a sûrement beaucoup
de Canadiens qui veulent le faire
qu'est-ce qui est le plus utile en ce
moment
mais aujourd'hui à l'heure actuelle
c'est vraiment de donner un apport
financier en tout cas aux organisations
qui sont déjà là qui ont déjà des
Programmes puis je pense de pas être
indifférent la souffrance des gens parce
que ça c'est le premier pas faut pas
être différent on sait que dans quelques
jours on va probablement passer à autre
chose mais ça va prendre une vie on a
deux nations qui vont être en deuil dans
les prochaines prochains jours prochains
mois et vous quand vous voyez ces images
de destruction terrible qu'est-ce que
vous ressentez
mais ça me rappelle Haïti beaucoup parce
que Haïti ça a été c'était extrêmement
troublant puis on voit on voit
aujourd'hui
où est le pays on souvent mémorise pas
rebâtir mieux comme c'était le slogan à
ce moment-là et je crois que il faut
durer dans la durée les Québécois pour
notre aide par rapport à c'est pas juste
maintenant aujourd'hui parce qu'on a eu
un petit ressenti en voyant une vidéo
déchirante mais ça va être pour les
prochains mois semaine c'est deux
nations en deuil auxquelles on fait face
aujourd'hui beaucoup beaucoup de
dommages merci beaucoup docteur lion
merci